INSTRUCTOR: All right.
So welcome back.
Picking up really quick
just where we left off,
talking about GitHub
or Git and GitHub.
I just want to show you
three last major things
that you may do in the
context of your work, at least
in the short term.
The world of Git
is very expansive.
We're not going to even get
close to covering all of it.
But again, like I was saying
before, the cool thing about it
is you typically have
a small set of commands
that you'll need to do, whether
that be as a software developer,
or data science, or
whatever that might be.
That Git add, Git
commit, and Git
push a set of commands,
that covers most of it.
But what we're going to
talk about in this video
is branching,
cloning, and forking.
So that'll hit the three main
other things we'll need to do.
First, from a
branching perspective.
The idea of a branch
is exactly what
it sounds like is there's
a main thread of work.
We already said we push
to the main branch.
You can picture that as this
ever-increasing versioning
of your work.
Then you can create
other branches.
This is typically done
if you have a feature,
let's say, you want to add.
You don't want to break
the main part of your code.
You want to keep that part
the same and functioning.
But if you want to
add this feature on
need a place to work
on it, pretty much.
And so that's what the idea
of a branch gives you is, hey,
I have a separate thread,
I'm going to go down.
So to look at the branches
available in your repo,
and again, like I
said, this is just
picking up exactly where we left
off with our midget project one.
So if you want to follow
along with the work,
you can go back
through the last video
and just follow those steps.
But I'll clarify that we're not
going to have you doing anything
explicitly.
At least right now, that
requires you to do this.
So if you just want to
watch along really quick,
so you see it.
And then if you ever need it for
a later activity, or assignment,
or anything else you do, you
have this as a reference point.
Anyway, Git branch.
We just have our main
branch right now.
If I want to create a new
feature branch and switch to it,
then I can do Git
checkout hyphen b.
And then we'll just
call it feature branch.
You can call it
whatever you want to.
But what we're saying is that,
hey, we're going to check out,
basically meaning you can think
about checking out our code.
We're going to check
out a feature branch.
And in the sense of, or in
this case, we don't have,
or this one doesn't exist
yet, so it'll be created,
and then we'll check it out.
And then we can go
in and make changes.
So it still looks
exactly the same.
If we LS, we just still have the
exact same code base we have.
We're basically creating
this branch off from where
we are at in the code base.
So if we do nano
readme, you'll see
that we're left off with this
charade of schools professor
at USU.
That was where we had
the main branch at.
And now, we're going right
off to the side of it
here with this branch.
And so we can make a
change to it and say,
well, my wife's a
professor at USU.
So I have to maybe say
charade is the second coolest
professor at USU.
And then I'll be polite and
say that my wife, Carly, is
the actual coolest.
Yep.
Just kind of.
Well, let's go back here.
So it's not.
Getting off the end
of the page over here.
Oh, my gosh.
Just do that.
Auto to the end here.
We'll just backspace
this and push it
on to a new slot, new line.
And it'll do it as
a special header.
Carly is the actual
coolest professor at USU.
So, now, we'll save this.
And if we note here,
though, on our main branch,
if I just hit the Refresh,
it hasn't changed anything
about this.
This is the code that we push to
our remote repository, our Git
repository, your
GitHub repository.
So we can push this up, though.
If we check here,
we'll see Git status.
We've modified our readme file.
So we can do Git add.
We'll add everything.
Git commit.
We'll say updated readme
on feature branch.
I need to clarify.
Git commit or hyphen m.
There we go.
And now, we're going
to do Git push.
But it's going to be
origin feature branch.
And then same thing as before.
We'll put in our username, and
we'll use our personal access
token for our password.
And now, if we hit Refresh here,
what do you expect to happen?
No change.
Well, that's because we're
still on our main branch.
We haven't actually changed
anything about our main branch.
But if you click
here, you will see now
that we have a feature
branch, we can click that.
And that will show our changes.
So you can see here, both of
these versions of code are live.
We can access both of them.
We can make changes
to either them.
We can push and pull
to each of them.
But we're in a
separate branch now.
We can also merge our branches,
though, by saying, hey, well,
I like the changes that I
made in this feature branch.
I want to bring that branch
right back into my main branch.
So I'll do Git checkout main.
That's going to check
out my main branch.
So, now, if I look at
what's in my readme file,
it shouldn't contain
the bit about Carly
because this is checking
out back to my main branch.
And then to merge in
my feature branch,
assuming there are no issues or
merge conflicts which we're not
going to get into
this course, you'll
take a more advanced course
that we'll cover that.
Then we'll just see great, one
file change, two insertions,
one deletion.
And now, if we look at our
readme file, that is in there.
And so our feature
branch looks the same.
We haven't changed anything
about our feature branch.
But if we go back
to our main branch,
we have to actually
push it, too.
So we've merged our
feature branch-- or yeah,
we merged in the changes
to our feature branch.
If you run Git
status now, you'll
see that we show
has nothing to push.
But our branch is ahead
of origin by one commit.
So now we're on Git push
origin main sharadkj.
And then I'll push that change.
And now, when I hit
Refresh on my main branch,
I'll see that change was made.
So that's the idea of
branching and merging code.
So the way to
think about this is
if you're working on
this with some buddies
and you're like, hey, we all
want to work on this main app
where we're building some
application together.
Well, you can decide.
You can start the main thread
basically with no code.
Just create the repository.
And then each of
you could go off
and create your
features of it and then
merge them back into main.
And so what will happen
then is like, hey,
if I need to pull in any changes
you made, I'll pull that in.
And so that's the
workflow to get into this.
We'll come back into that
at the very end here.
There's one more
piece that we need
to do before we can fully
understand this pipeline.
But I do also want
to show what it
looks like to pull code
or better statement
to clone a repository.
So a lot of times
when you're starting
on a new project or a new task,
you might find somebody else
has written code already has
a GitHub repo that already
contains the code that's
necessary for what you're
trying to do.
And so cloning a
repository is exactly what
it sounds like is
we're going to go to.
So let's say here I've
pulled up this one here.
It's the, hello, world.
So
github.com/octocat/Hello-world.
So this is from GitHub,
the company just
as a practice repository.
And so you can see
this one right here.
All it contains is
a single readme file
as well that just
says hello, world.
And if I want to
clone this repository.
Well first, I'm going to back
out of my Git, my current Git
repository.
So I'm just back in
the home directory.
And then all I have to
do is come over here,
click on this code, copy
this link, this HTTPS link,
and then I'll run
Git clone that.
And now if we run ls,
you'll see that we've
copied all of this code over.
So you could see the
over to hello, world.
And you would have access
to this file in here.
If we cat the readme,
we'll see that we can now
see this hello, world there.
So it's that easy,
which is really nice.
So, again, anybody
that you come across
of all the countless
GitHub repositories.
Let me see if I can
find just like the--
Yeah, so you can see here
there's a feed in your profile.
So let's say, for example, this
random practical PyTorch GitHub
repository is interesting to me.
I could come here and say,
all this code is helpful.
Great.
I'll copy this link
and I'll run Git clone
and pull down all
of that code as well
and have it right there ready
to go on my EC2 instance.
So this is a great easy
fast way to copy code over.
Just come there, clone
the repository locally.
Similarly, we can also
fork repositories.
So we're actually going to
clone a different one for this.
So we're going to do Git clone.
And it's going to look similar.
So I'll actually just tap
up and go back to this one.
It's still from
Octocat, I believe.
Actually, first to do that.
So I'm going to come
over to the link.
I think one of these
is actually the link.
OK, it's not.
So let me just pull
up this one again.
So it's Octocat.
But this one is slash
spoon, hyphen knife.
So this, again, a demo repo.
But it's for you to practice
specifically forking code.
Hence the fun name spoon knife.
But either way, the
idea behind cloning
a repository is that you are--
or sorry, forking repository,
is that it's different
than a branch.
A branch is saying, hey,
there's the main thread.
And then I'm creating
a branch with the idea
that this branch is going to
come back in at some point
and merge back into my code.
A fork is saying, hey, starting
from where this code is at,
I want to make my
own version of this.
I'm going to have my own
thread running for that.
So that might mean, hey, I
have a base or existing code
base that does
something really cool.
But I want to build an entirely
new set of features on it.
And I'm not part of
the organization.
So let's say this is, I think,
this is a great repository,
a cool website.
This index.html is
our website here.
I want to create my
own version of this.
I'm not part of the
Octocat organization.
So I can't really make any
changes and I can't merge,
my branch back in here.
So, instead, I'm
going to fork my code
and then work from that one.
And so to do that,
well, what you do
is you-- let's just
drag this over.
So it's a little easier to see.
What you're going to
do is come over here
where you see this fork button.
Click that, create a new fork.
And notice it's
going to make you
the owner now of a
new repository that's
starting from that main
branch or whatever branch
you choose to start from.
And so we'll create the fork.
Take a couple of seconds.
And then once that's done, we
now have that exact same code.
It's showing all of the
commits from the past.
So it still gives us all the
11 years of history of this.
But it's now owned by
me, or this version of it
is owned by me.
So I can come over here to the
code, link here, copy that link.
So notice I'm back
on my home directory.
So if you're not, you
can just cd tilde.
Then I'll do Git clone.
Paste this link.
And now I have cloned the
spoon knife repository back
to my machine.
And so if I cd into
spoon knife, then
let's edit our index.html page.
And so we'll change this text
down here that says fork me,
fork you @octocat.
They thought that
was really clever.
I'm going to change this to
say this is Sharad's fork now.
Then we'll save that.
And so we make sure that stuck.
Yeah.
OK.
So you can see our changes
here from a cat standpoint.
So, now, all I'm
going to do is same
as I've done before, if you
look at the Git status, great.
We've modified this.
You guys know this by now.
Git add.
Git commit.
And then I'll say made changes
to index.html page and Git push
origin main.
And let me grab my personal
access token again.
Paste enter.
Now I should be able
to come over here.
Refresh this page.
See the most recent push
right here made changes
to index.html page.
And if we come down here,
we see all this code
pushed successfully.
And so that's what it
means to fork a code is now
this is my own code base.
I can go and do
whatever I want to this.
But there may be a
situation now where
I say, hey, the
changes I made to this
are actually really meaningful.
I think I want to
merge this back in.
Or better statement,
I want this to go back
into the original code base.
So what I'll do is I'll come
back over here to my link
or to my repository.
Then I'll click this
idea of pull request.
So a pull request
is interesting name.
What it means is that I
am pulling this code back
into the main branch.
Actually, I want to do this.
Let's go back to the Octocat.
And I think I can submit
this on the Octocat one.
Let's go all the way back.
Octocat.
Yeah.
There we go.
So what we're
saying now is we've
made some meaningful
changes that we
think should be in
the core database
or in the core code base.
And so a pull request is how I
can request that is, I'm saying,
hey, I request that
you pull my code
into the main thread, the main
development thread of this.
So notice here, I'm
on the Octocat page.
I'm on their profile here.
And I'll say, hey, I have
a new pull request to make.
And then I guess I should
have done the branch.
See, I will do this for mine.
Never mind.
We'll do this for mine.
I'll make it a little easier.
Just because I'll have
permissions to show it here.
Yeah.
There we go.
That's actually
perfect example here.
So you can either do it
from that pull request page,
or you'll notice
here that I'm now
one commit ahead of the
Octocat spoon knife.
Well, I can contribute
this code back
by just opening a pull request.
And so what I've said is
like, hey, my code is--
and you see here it's
saying the base repository
is Octocat spoon knife.
The head repository is mine.
And I said I made meaningful
changes to this index.html page.
And I could add a description
or whatever I want to.
And then I can click
Create Pull Request.
And this will literally post
right there onto their page.
And so now they see,
hey, Sharad thinks
that he's added some
meaningful changes to this.
They can click and
see what this is here.
Removed this line.
Added this line.
And then because I don't have
write access to this repository,
I can't actually make
this pull request.
I can't make them merge this
back into the main branch.
But I can at least
put this out there.
And they'll see
this notification.
And then they'll have the
opportunity to go in here
and actually make this request.
And you're welcome to do this
exact same process as well.
That's why they developed
this repository,
as well as to practice
forking repositories.
So you're not going to
be bothering anybody
by making this pull request.
But practically
speaking, if I was
doing this within
the company, this
would be the equivalent
of me saying, hey,
whoever's managing
this code base,
or whoever's allowed to
manage this code base,
you should review my code
and decide whether this
should be pulled in or not.
So that covers the main thing.
And I guess I'll
add to this as well.
Pull request is a
specific name to GitHub.
Other platforms might
call them merge requests
because they're saying, well,
you're merging this code back
into the main branch.
There's philosophies
on either side of it.
We won't worry about that.
But it's all the
same idea of saying,
hey, this is how you
formally merge the code back
into the code base.
So as I was saying, this is
the whole picture of everything
that there is, at least
practically that you'll need
to do in your day-to-day job.
Working as a web developer,
software developer,
data scientist,
whoever is writing
any sort of collaborative code.
It's really, really
important skill set.
So practice this a ton.
Use this as an
opportunity to start
to create your online portfolio
where you push all your code to.
Even showing a long
history of using GitHub
is oftentimes looked
as a positive.
If you've made a
lot of contributions
either to your own
repositories or even better
made meaningful contributions to
public open source repositories.
That will really highlight
to future employers
that, hey, this
person knows what
they're doing in this space.
So we'll leave it
at that for now.
Hopefully, with
this whole picture,
you'll have a go-to resource
for GitHub and Git in general.
But feel free to shoot me any
questions or comments you have.
The last thing is
I'll say, again,
once you're done with
your EC2 instance,
feel free to terminate it.
I'm going to do that
right now before I forget.
So we'll terminate
this instance.
So perfect.
We'll leave it at that.
And then I will catch up
with you guys next time.
Bye.